brandon howard
thanks for having me alan i know
i'm excited i'm excited it's like it's
our anniversary it is our anniversary it
is
it is a trip anniversary that's right we
kicked it off at transtech
that's right 2019 end of the year
shout out to trans technology absolutely
for jeffrey martin the whole team
absolutely yeah absolutely they um
they're angels
i i hope they're aware of how angelic
they are because
what they're doing is a crucial very
crucial and i'm very grateful
yeah yeah maximizing health and
well-being and leveraging technology to
do so
and basically why you were there and why
we interviewed you there for round one
with euphoria
and now we're gonna unpack in round two
more nuance around the
psychology of sound and we have an act
we have a
we're gonna do the app demo which first
time right
the first time yeah first time here in
la we're doing the app demo
which is pumped i'm i appreciate it
because i've needed this um i think i
have a lot of users or a lot of people
that are curious
that would love more details on this and
i
uh i i need your technical skills to
bring it to the public
yeah and we're right there you're
getting a little taste of it off the bat
we're gonna be streaming our phone
screen into the
stream and you guys will also get to
hear
the audio of what brandon has put
together
in order to actually eradicate stress
and boost creativity and many more
things which
will unpack i'm just super pumped that
we have this
to along with the process
so brandon let's let's jump into your
journey we'll start there sure so who
were you growing up and how did you get
interested in this space um
all right so i grew up uh i was born in
buffalo new york
son to anastasia and eugene howard
they raised me in south carolina and
i learned we learned pretty quickly just
how different
you know an environment can be i think
it took us like
you know one like five minutes off the
plane one trip to the grocery store to
have like somebody like ram their cart
into us and just like
tell us we're in the wrong store so um
we knew
that you know when we moved there it was
going to be challenging but i
i had a bunch of great people a bunch of
great friends who just sort of
you know gave me a safe place to grow up
and i think that's what
a lot of people need um and and
i guess from there it was you know i
pushed myself as kind of like you know i
had to prove myself
athletically academically uh and again
i benefited to uh got the opportunity to
play basketball at brown university
um again push myself academically and
athletically
and i think that's kind of when i burned
out my junior year of college
i um i stopped playing basketball i
graduated i got a job but
i started experiencing like just pain
all the time i was constantly stretching
constantly aching
and you know i started to yeah i ignored
it for a while and
eventually you start to get
professionals to look into it
acupuncturists physical therapy
um chiropractors massage therapy i was
doing at least
two of those things two times a week
[Laughter]
all the time and again like you know i'm
growing up getting married i go train
for a half marathon that's
how my wife and i decided to get in
shape for the wedding and
it actually um that's that's when my
back went out
completely i was on a treadmill in the
gym and i felt like
lava pouring down my spine like
something had like
i ruptured a disc and i couldn't look
into it until after the wedding
so after the wedding like it was awesome
it was fine
um and the pain like comes and goes for
people that have chronic pain
uh and um you know they diagnosed me and
told me that i had
the back of a 90 year old that i had two
herniations
and at least one rupture and that i was
on pace for another one
so they sent me to physical therapy like
a different physical therapist
and they gave me pain meds and i think
that's kind of when my emotions
kind of just like like exploded like a
volcano
um because as i was going through this
process of trying to
rehab my back and try to get back to
like being athletic or playing
basketball like
my wife and i had just had a son and we
you know we i couldn't i couldn't change
his diaper i couldn't bend him over i
couldn't pick him up
everything hurt everything hurt and
being in constant pain just
made me really irritable i mean that's a
nice way of putting it my wife has
been through a lot just like dealing
with like just my constant mood swings
because when you're in pain
all the time there's nothing else to
think about and
what i wound up experiencing was that
when you're ex when you're having
negative thoughts when you're angry
like that's when my back would actually
just have another like episode
like i would just be frustrated
frustrated frustrated my back would go
out
and then i'd be in bed for like two days
um just like really unable to move
and eventually that cost me my job
because i missed one meeting because i
couldn't afford to miss one meeting
um and i missed that meeting and uh you
know that was kind of like the beginning
of the end for me
so i wound up um you know i i
didn't have that job anymore and you
know i didn't really i hadn't
learned about binaural beats at that
point and i had
kind of been curious about it but it was
after
physical therapy had stopped working it
was after you know
i had stopped taking the pain meds
because they were sort of only making me
angrier
and so i wound up um you know
looking back into binaural beats my wife
was like maybe you should like you know
just dig back into it and see see if
there's something there because she had
seen that
i had a lot of interest and confidence
in it and that it was looking to be
something very significant
and so you know without a job and
curious about
you know how to heal my back i started
to build
you know uh i guess a business model
around you know
what binaural beats can do is incredible
and i'm using it to help me deal with
like the physical pain
the emotional stress that's leading to
more physical pain
and it got me to a place where i could
you know i could start to pay attention
to
what's important and how to balance that
and you know create essentially i guess
like a
just a new approach to life
so um yeah it was it was
been interesting i can get into like the
entrepreneurial element of it because
you know once you have an idea and like
that's all fun um
you know the first few things i pitched
for more around creative ideas like
books and novels and graphic novels and
stuff but
um you know i dealt with a lot of
frustration
with trying to penetrate that industry i
i went to i won't name names but i went
into a meeting at a very large like
talent agency and i asked them um
do you feel like the content you put out
impacts society
or is it just a reflection of society
and his answer was that it was just a
reflection of it
and i was already sort of aware at that
point just how impactful media can be
and i think now everybody's seeing how
impactful media can be i mean the
messages that you get are the messages
you incorporate into your reality
and now we have different groups reading
different
information and expressing completely
different
theories uh we've always had multiple
theories but
to to have sort of like mass groups
around differentiating theories like in
the past that's led to conflict and i
think right now we need to figure out a
way to not let that happen
so yeah the journey on the
entrepreneurial side is
it's complicated um because there's no
real rules there's there's there's a lot
of guidelines a lot of suggestions
um essentially it's about people with
ideas trying to connect with people with
the means to make those ideas a reality
and
you wind up you know it's it's like it's
there's a lot of analogies to dating i
mean yeah there's a lot of strikeouts
there's a lot of there's a lot of downs
there's a lot of it didn't work out and
and without though i think a lot of some
people have
the perception of whatever doesn't work
is just like that lesson
that you need to learn so that way the
next time it does work
and i always knew that was
a good approach but it didn't mean that
it wasn't a painful approach yeah
so um if anything along this time i've
just learned the importance of balancing
you know my perspective and my emotions
with the situations
because you know i guess my life
experience when
when i lose that control is when things
happen that i wind up
stressing and regretting like later so
i've
guess i'm naturally proactively avoiding
danger i guess
it helps being 6'5 when i was living in
new york like but i
i also knew when not to ride the train
what neighborhoods not to go to like
where the violence was and
you know i and eventually
the funny thing was i kind of dictated
those places based off like music
i mean i'm pretty sure ice cube said if
you ain't never been to the ghetto don't
ever come to the ghetto and i'm just
like well
i'm from the suburbs i don't think they
want me so
but at the same time i was like we
really need to figure out how to get
along
and and if anything i've learned just
how
artificial media can be which is why i
gravitate to the
to the truth seekers to the to the
reporters that have their
finger on the pulse of what's important
to the documentarians who are
willing to spend their last dime on a
message that is more valuable than
you know the money that they get from
from producing it so
yeah that's that's how i like to build
my knowledge base
yeah yeah so so many good things to hit
back there so
i really like how when you talk about
your journey it's almost like this
very purposeful pressure cooker occurred
in your health trajectory
that caused you to awaken to the
importance of your own temple of the
body
yeah and like there's that part of it
and then there's also how that led to
missing that meeting that led to the job
being gone which then enabled you to
pursue entrepreneurship
at the same time and you were looking at
binaural beats at the time
as well and it sounds like your wife
also kind of gave you
like a little nudge and was like you
know get pursuing in that kind of stuff
which
is good it's always really important to
have that that that
couple that acts as a flame and then
together
and then also that you were you kind of
had like a synthesis
perspective regarding like you said you
were doing
chiropractic acupuncture all of these
you're drawing from all these different
physical therapy all these different
fields in
and you were seeing different people and
it was like what's actually
helping my body truly become the temple
and healing what i need to do decreasing
my stress increasing my
creativity my familial abilities as a
husband as a father etc
and so i really like that
the i really appreciate in the stories
when
the pressure cooker really tells the
story well about
why you're where you are today and in
this case it totally
lines up yeah yeah it's i
i probably have curated that story
because of sort of the self-reflection
required
to get rid of the
the what was triggering the
the negative thoughts um ultimately
like like we were getting to
is how where your thoughts are is pretty
much
it dictates your experience and so um
when you're feeling physical pain like
that's kind of like all that you pay
attention to
and so to get past the pain
you kind of like and and when everything
ex
like on the exterior isn't working for
you like the last option you kind of
have is to like just look within
and i was yeah i didn't know what that
meant
at the time like i didn't that concept
didn't exist until i saw the matrix
but knowing myself is everybody's unique
path
to getting past whatever it is that's
creating that sort of like psychological
like barrier to progress
so um so yeah it's the pressure cooker
all these things that you know drive
your emotions
um i think that for me like anybody that
grew up with me knew that i was the most
emotional kid on the team like
i could not tolerate striking out in
baseball i did not like
losing anything um and so
you know all those life lessons they
make you angry in the moment
and then you look back and i mean you
can say that
be grateful for for where you're at like
i'm grateful for where i'm at right now
with what i'm doing and i'm grateful for
all the
exterior events that pushed me in this
direction um
but it's it i wouldn't have gotten here
until i started to actually
recognize that those exterior events
were
helping me along my journey and they
were
inspiring the um you know just the
they were inspiring the actions like you
know people's gut reactions are built up
because of their life experiences
and so my gut reaction was to you know
when i had the injuries like if they
can't
figure it out for me i have to figure it
out myself yes and
then when you see the reasons why they
couldn't help me and like what's
motivating
healthcare and hospitals and doctors and
why they prescribe me pain meds instead
of surgery like
all these things go into the fact that
the systems we live in are incredibly
inefficient i think that's probably
sort of um the thing that i pay
attention to the most is inefficiencies
because
inefficiencies seem to be what drive my
irritation yeah
so when i see efficiency like how you
work
i'm impressed and and when i see
products out there that don't drive me
nuts
i'm impressed yes and i you know when i
see business models
for companies out there like patagonia
like those are the inspirations that
that drive me to create something that
can
help in all the different places that i
feel help was needed
yeah yeah
we definitely passed a good chunk of
time before we started on the inclusive
stakeholding architectures which we
hopefully will
touch on as we get through some of the
euphoria
content so sound
is miraculous
and we must leverage it for those
miracles
and sound is not something to be
just passive about it's something to be
actively
engaged with and so we can
we can because you you you've said this
and this was really interesting that
we can use positive natural energy in
the bands of frequencies
as beneficial as the food that we eat
right and so we'll we'll explore this on
the app but there's
literally different bands of frequencies
for different states of
awareness that you want to trigger with
binaural beats
sure yeah just super cool yeah if you if
you pull up the
infographic that i gave you the one for
um
sound psychology yes gosh i love this
one
yeah okay thank you it's such a good one
all right let's go in all right all
right so this is um
this is a little i mean it's i wanted it
to be
colorful and bright and easy to
understand for people
uh of all ages um because there's an
element to
color psychology and that is something
that's very well studied and it's about
how different colors trigger different
emotional reactions in people
and as sort of you as you look at it i
mean if you
just take a color like something you see
like obviously like there's rainbows in
the sky and they have these colors
but within the if you look at it
on the electromagnetic spectrum you
realize
that there's these bands of color on one
end
and then you've got bands of sound down
here on the other end
and when i saw that there was a
mathematical correlation
that you could calculate either from
sound to light or from light to sound
then i knew that there was a connection
that would draw on
what these elements um impact and so
the first thing that i looked at was the
psychology or sorry um
you know color psychology and they
mentioned how
and there's still studies coming out
about this now i just read one recently
but
around the world people have generally
the same responses to red the same
responses to orange like
everybody sort of feels either sort of
like
uh driven to anger or driven a passion
or or feeling grounded
whenever they see red like these are the
common themes that people share
um and how how people have anxiety when
they go into rooms that are yellow like
that happened to me i
do not want to go into a room with
yellow walls on it because
it's sort of it i have a negative
reaction to it
but i didn't understand until more
recently that that negative reaction was
anxiety
and how if you have um
and that's the thing is that everybody
sort of has to measure
where they're at what is their emotional
response to a stimulus because that
kind of is like your dna where
if you see red and you get angry and i
see red
and i get motivated like if we have to
work on something and we're stuck in a
red room we might not be able to
collaborate
so it's important to understand like how
you react to things and what your
emotional reaction is because
that will dictate not only how you
handle a situation
and how your um it's essentially how
your subconscious gets developed
and then from there if your subconscious
gets developed to react to something in
a negative way you will do that your
whole life
and when you do that you start to get
into the endocrine system
and how hormones um sort of get
uh produced and so when you when you
look at this particular um
spectrum it's it's recognizing sort of
like
where you at where are you at throughout
the day what what's impacting you
and i know you're scrolling down um the
part that i skipped um up at the top
was actually how you know as this uh
scroll down to the middle like the food
section
actually because the funny thing is
is that back when you talk about ancient
greece
there's a lot of talk about how food was
medicine and
the one thing about that is um you can
use the same sort of
psychological uh responses to say like
okay you need
to eat more apples you need to eat more
lemons you need to eat more greens uh
greens
you know to give you guys a quick
metaphor green is associated with the
heart chakra
and green is also associated with
vegetables which impact
um sorry your heart and lungs actually
and then the
vitamins that are in you know green
foods that we eat are
there for helping your blood system your
cardiovascular
system your heart and lungs essentially
so all these people that are struggling
with certain diseases
there's a little bit more research needs
to be done to truly prove it
but this theory has been based off the
fact that
if you are experiencing a certain type
of negative emotion you're building up
negative or or stress related hormones
in that particular part of your body
and then 11 to 40 years later you're
going to wind up going to the hospital
talking about you have a chronic
condition because you've been stressing
about the same thing
your whole life building up that um
just just building up that inflammation
like it's gonna you're not gonna feel it
and then it's gonna feel like an ache or
a pain um it could be in your heart your
chest it could be anywhere on your body
your hormones find places to like hang
out and if they don't get cleaned out by
your parasympathetic nervous system
then they just sit there so it's really
important for you to have those positive
moments in your life
because that's the only thing a positive
thought is literally the only thing
that's going to counteract
the internal stress that's building up
in all of us
so that's that's uh that that's why this
is so important to me this is this is my
perspective and this is what i've found
and and it's kept me i haven't been to a
chiropractor
acupuncturist physical therapist in
at least three years maybe four wow
yeah yeah so you just find ways to to
get through your own problems beautiful
yeah yeah
wow so
if i'm getting this right
we've now had a period of time
has it been like 50 years 100 years when
did this first come to
light the idea of sound psychology do we
know how old this is oh this goes all
the way back
is this like thousands of years this is
this is the origins of
human species
okay sound in terms of biological
evolution from
the cellular biochemical level yes yeah
but
but in terms of like so our analysis
of the the electromagnetic spectrum in
terms of light and then comparing that
to sound and then
saying that this area is associated with
this style of emotion
this area is associated with this style
of emotion how about that how
well how old is that that's probably
what maybe 150
or so 50 or 100 years i don't have a
date
on the psychology of color because james
clark maxwell was like
150 years ago and that was like
electromagnetism and so we had to come
up with that
formulation first sure to scientifically
try and begin
yeah the interesting thing for me which
um
obviously i don't have the scientific
background as a lot of like
sound engineers or or you know medical
doctors and professionals
so for me it's always a challenge of
like trying to convince people like why
i did this
and like why it's right yeah because i
kind of skipped a lot of steps
in order to test the theory yeah i i
read a lot of things
and it felt like everything was aligning
to where
this can have a positive impact yes and
so
that's when i i used it on myself i
asked a couple friends that they were
interested i would ask people if they
wanted to buy into this
that's kind of also how i learned sort
of the the importance of introducing
something to
the audience um because this is very
similar to me and it's very similar to a
lot of other people because
i have also done a similar process in
terms of
synthesizing from the peaks of the
fitness landscape but i'm i'm gonna have
a theory
on on consciousness and metaphysics
but i'm not going to tell you about the
uh uh tony oni's uh
integrated information theory or stuart
hameroff's correlates of
consciousness and microtubules you know
i know those at a at a abstract level
but i'm not going to dive into depth
so i i hear you and a lot of sort of
like synthesis entrepreneurs
yeah they're not going into the depths
of what a physicist knows about this
type of things yeah
so just add an i just wanted to take it
at a at a
at a level in terms of like you first
started
seeing the possibilities of this
being used for triggering
uh states of awareness in the last
couple of years
yeah okay so i would are other people
doing that too like
like binaurals for states of awareness
a good amount of people now are i would
say that
i've seen a couple of companies that are
using binaural beats binaural beats
themselves
are good for getting you into sleep mode
meditation mode relaxed mode focus mode
that's what binaural beats do
okay the way euphoria creates their
binaural beats
we use the psychology of color and
that allows us to sort of map um
mathematically the frequencies of sound
to the frequencies of color and so
that mathematical bridge allows us to do
like
it allows us to prove it to a point
because on the
vibrational side the sound side that
practice has been mostly established
by uh monks um oh
interesting so that goes back yeah yeah
folks the monks monks have been using
sound as a healing modality going back
to their origins and i think the
egyptians as well in their like
big chambers i was getting to that yeah
i don't know if
you know the other sort of yeah
spiritual traditions have
had been using that style of yeah i see
where you're where you're
getting at okay yeah so ultimately they
um they have
egyptians had these healing chambers and
the healing chamber where people would
go and lie down
they would be connected to all the other
pyramids that were nearby
so each pyramid their individual shape
was generating a unique vibration
and they were channeling that sound to
the healing chamber so that taught me
that they were channeling specific
frequencies in order for specific
effects yeah
so looking into that knowing that monks
were using it
seeing what um you know just sort of
like a lot of the
the ancient philosophers like a lot of
them crushed on both sides
it's crazy how we forgot how to fish in
this case
did we be in this case we were our
ancestors were
potential to teach us how to fish using
yeah the frequencies are there just use
sound and like this is what we're doing
buried and forgotten about because yeah
you're right it's there from thousands
of years
yeah and i mean you have to look at
ancient greece because they were the
ones who were bringing that knowledge
from egypt
and they had it and
they even knew they even used food as
medicine like they talked about using it
and then we somehow gravitated to the
hippocratic oath of not paying attention
to sound or food
and and and for me i didn't take the
hippocratic oath
of do no harm i just
found that sound is less harmful and i
would love for doctors to do less harm
yeah let's identify like you were saying
in the earlier part
all of the alternative forms of
healing that are available to
keep us in peak homeostatic capacity
like 18 year old biorejuvenation levels
uh throughout our life for longevity but
also in terms of
nudging us creatively towards our north
stars
and towards lower levels of stress and
what you were just mentioning a moment
ago
in the psychology of sound graphic uh
here i just want to walk people through
kind of what
is going on in your app so you know when
you guys open up
when you guys open up the euphoria app
and you're
you can download that and the link in
the bio below there's the
the ios download link down there
highly recommend giving this a go it's
free it is
super on point for all of these
different ways that you want to feel
what you want to boost
while you blank and it's awesome in this
case i've went and selected
a couple settings but i'm only going to
show you what the center
portion looks like so when you click the
middle part where it says
and boost my okay so when you click that
you begin seeing the
and you can walk us through yeah this
yeah absolutely because this is what we
were talking about a little
moment ago in the psychology of sound
right so um
just starting from the top you can see
like the solfeggio name right there
the selfegeo frequencies are you know
that is
the element of euphoria that delivers
the emotional impact
um and so the sulfagio frequencies like
you know that is what was largely used
by gregorian monks um and
and for me when i realized that
meditation was something that could
improve my health i looked at the the
people who did it
and i started to understand why they did
it and monks have that resilience
because
they they hum they chant and the hum
that they make resonates internally with
the different organs that they have in
their bodies so
humming at 396 is going to vibrate your
root chakra but humming at
528 is going to vibrate your solar
plexus and so you don't even need to
know the mathematical frequencies you
just need to adjust your hum
until you feel the vibration in the
right spot and this is is this why
in the lineage of specifically
the uh the the indian
traditions that the mantras are very
popular and the
oh
and all of those other sort of layers
on the chakras of where to right
to use the frequencies
yeah and it's a chakras is the
sort of the origin from the eastern
cultures to my understanding like
understand that i grew up in south
carolina in the bible belt
none of this stuff was ever spoken of i
think i heard the name buddha once and
it was probably from like a wu-tang song
no kidding bro this is why did it take
me
26 years to learn what anando was
you know existence consciousness bliss
why does it take that long why are we
not taught about these concepts in
school
and this type of stuff yeah it's it's an
educational thing i think
we will get there
that's the future we're we're gonna
we're all pioneering that with what
we're talking about on the show and
stuff yeah
yeah but ultimately it's um in the east
it's chakras or in some parts of the
east it's chakras in the west it's the
endocrine system like
we have glands in all the same places
that these chakras are
um as are listed and essentially it just
shows that chakras were just
ahead in terms of knowledge and wisdom
and so we're just catching up
and the people who incorporate this into
their lives they
they experience the benefits of just
being calm and just being relaxed and
enjoying their environments um
so in any case the way you can use uh
this app to get there
is the first um there's a few ways like
some people who
want to use it for like athletic related
things
um we can get to another uh maybe we'll
do that one last
um because we can jump to another uh
document i shared with you
oh yeah let's do that now right i don't
know we'll talk about this this first
yeah this first and and just to give you
guys an an idea
this is like holy cow we're we're
talking look
here listen to listen to the range
vitality creativity willpower love
self-expression focus consciousness pain
relief
cure all vigor rejuvenation and we're
and we're we haven't even hit sort of
the main
themes that when brandon pop published
his white paper just
a couple days ago that his main themes
that he listed in it were
that he's aiming to tackle with euphoria
insomnia
anxiety depression stress burnout sports
recovery
creativity focus pain management heart
rate variability
adhd meditation relaxation i mean
this is like you're you can really cover
a vast
majority of the ways that people want to
de-stress and boost themselves
yeah yeah and i wanted it to be flexible
so that everybody could have their own
experience with it
um i said before i think everybody has
their own unique path
um based off their life experiences and
sort of like what their soul
kind of like pushes them into into
choosing and the choices that they make
so you can use euphoria to one say
i want to i want to stop this
negative behavioral pattern whether it's
a thought that you have or something
that you constantly do but
recognize the emotional uh response that
you have
to that situation because if you can
find the negative
um on here we call it shift from if you
can
find what's bothering you then you
already have an idea of what you can
listen to to feel better
oh shift from and shift to okay
because here the you know in the in the
breakdown we have
there's a the solfeggio and then there's
the schumann
sure and then okay so there's those two
and then we have
um the shift from and shift two
which i think is really interesting that
you incorporate that because here you
have
you know shift from physical pain to
shift to pain reduction or shift from
illness to wellness or from fatigue to
renewed
or from chronic ailments to cellular
rehabilitation those are just a couple
of them
and so that's really interesting that um
that you you incorporate that because
it's in a sense you're
you're driving people from um from
a specific state that they're
experiencing to upstate that they want
to go to and you make that explicit
what clarity is such a crucial thing
there that's really smart that you did
that well thank you i i definitely
wanted to minimize confusion and this is
uh clearly something that they don't
teach us a lot about in school
um and so as an entrepreneur i can say
that
that's very important and a lot of
entrepreneurs need to work on this
specific thing which is
decreasing confusion and increasing
clarity
and you definitely did that here and
i'll give a i'll give a big shout out to
to neon roots uh aka rootstrap
they have um when i when i got to work
with them
um their team there was so mindful so
mindful i mean like their app developer
this is the app developer that i worked
with cool neon
neon roots neon roof shadow roots yeah
um so yeah they uh they helped me sort
of
keep this clean like they knew that that
was the direction i wanted to go
and they were able to help me execute on
that so
um but yeah it's it's being
able to know where you want to go it's
setting intentions i mean there's so
much science on the the benefits of
setting a positive
intention and that is how i design
euphoria
create your intention and then let
euphoria keep you there as long as you
want to be there
and honestly people that use it
you'll know that it's really working
either when you
move to different combinations or you
don't need it anymore at all yes like
i just i don't need to create things
that people need to stay addicted to
exactly
but people will find an attraction to
something that works that's right they
always do
right and so when people say like is it
something that i could get addicted to
it's like hopefully
but at the same time it's something that
is not going to be a crutch
because yes you're empowering yourself
every time you listen to a combo
and then you won't need that combo to
get in that mind state the next time
spot on 100 every single
spiritual tradition that is worth their
salt they
are the ones that say that you know
as you try and re-commune with god
you come here you undergo the process
but these are training wheels and so all
the transformative technology
this is that exists like euphoria all of
the meditation retreats all these
peak performances on antiogens what have
you
they're training wheels to eventually be
able to not
need the training wheels anymore and
then you're literally
as rupert spira says is that once the
journey to
god ends the journey in god begins
and so that's the idea is that you
really want to be able to anchor in this
the ways uh these and you can trigger
yourself
you want to literally be in that state
yourself
but it's also important that you know
the way that this
sort of makes you feel it's kind of like
revisiting a book or a movie
or music after a year or after a couple
months or after a couple years whatever
is that
there's new ways that these meditation
retreats or
transform of technologies make us feel
like you can re
you can kind of re-up in a sense back up
you can re-baseline yourself higher
and higher over time so there are
reasons to also revisit which is an
interesting
phenomenon and so i it's probably
helpful
um to just show if if there isn't
another
graphic that you think is oh yeah i was
going to say it you could pull up yeah
so a friend of mine uh yeah okay a
friend of mine
he is and he's just a strong human being
um he is focused he's uh driven by
a lot of things and uh what he's done
for me is he's used euphoria while he
wears a wearable
and so the wearable that he has is
called woop and
it allows him if you scroll down a
little bit how one soldier boosts
recovery while he sleeps
yeah so he's a he's a west point grad
um and i wish i knew all his credentials
i don't understand the military
uh yeah to the significant detail bro
do you how do you bring your a game
every day
yeah so what he does is
he will create a combination on euphoria
he'll listen to it while he sleeps and
then when he wakes up his wearable will
say
you know this is how your body responded
and so the stats that you're seeing on
this
is like you know listening to euphoria
improves your resting heart rate
uh which is important for um boosting
your recovery
uh and and mitigating stress while
sleeping yep
um and so the next one down talks about
uh heart rate variability and how much
that has an impact on people so right
now if you have an apple watch
or or any wearable device you're already
paying attention to
um how your heart rate variability uh
impacts your stress levels how you
handle situations i mean
that's what fluctuates when you feel
your heart skip like if something
impacts you so deeply like that is i
mean that is that's you're feeling your
heart
like skip a beat and so when you can
catch that at a subtler level you can
recognize the things
that will make your heart skip a beat
but if you
never know that it's making your heart
seem beat one day it's going to skip too
much
and so and just the scientific idea of
the heart rate variability from what i
understand also has to do with
when you do experience higher levels of
stress cortisol
when you're in fight or flight the
sympathetic nervous system
your your heart rate variability becomes
it becomes
there is very low heart rate variability
so it's just doo
doo doo doo doo and when you're
in a state of relaxation your heart rate
variability is very high so it might be
dudu
and it might be do do you know it might
it might jump a little bit
between so there's more variability well
it's it's
i think that a lot of us expect our
brains to
be the best processor for
how we're experiencing things but the
heart rate variability
is it's i don't know if that's more of
the machine like
whatever the response is this is how the
heart adapts to it
and i think that our brain and so our
heart can tell us what we should
go towards and what we should stay away
from but i think that
our brains wind up having a little bit
more say
like in what we ultimately wind up doing
because as humans we have a choice
if we didn't have a choice we probably
only follow our hearts
yeah now that we do have a choice we
have to choose to follow our hearts
and that requires effort if you've never
done it before yeah
and so there's there's a lot of tools
out there that
are trying to build that connection and
inspire that and that's one of the
things that i wanted to do with euphoria
yeah and do we
think that there's another graphic
before we should move to
sure so if we're talking about the if
we're going to move into the white paper
let's open up that last infographic
um this is the cover image
okay this one has both yeah i guess
so essentially once we released
uh euphoria um it was october of 2017
and what we wound up doing was
we're trying to it was an mvp it is an
mvp the app that's out there is still an
mvp
um because we wanted to find out
if it worked how people will respond to
it um
was it truly beneficial is this
something that requires
more research and financial investment
all those things that entrepreneurs have
to think about
when they are explaining a product to
somebody that they need help from and as
entrepreneurs we tend to need a lot of
help from financial investors
and so financial investors want proof
and
you can give them the app and they can
listen to it and they can say it
impacted me but they want
to know how much is it impacting other
people
how how how effective is it and so i
wanted to write this white paper to show
what we found in our three years of this
data analysis
so so this is three years of data
analysis
yeah so october 2017 in october 2020
um wow we've reached over 36 000 users
again
with a minimal budget it's all been like
word of mouth marketing and advertising
um and i is it probably because we could
probably go through multiple demos maybe
um before we unpack the white paper
nuance we should do one of the demos for
the
yeah yeah absolutely absolutely so
people can get a taste of it and then
we'll explain the
data from white paper okay okay all
right so um let's
let's put i think um i just wanna before
you'll tell us what
to do in it i just wanna i just wanna
show people
that in the when you guys do get
in here um what what
what you see is you see that there's um
the i want to feel
which is at the top which we didn't get
to go over with you guys yet
um and so that's where we have that this
idea of the
the the solfeggio gamma oneness
there's the sofagio gamma intuitive
there's the solfeggio gamma so they're
just slightly lower
hurts on the gamma and then you have
resolved you have
harmonious you have miraculous
cleansed liberation
and so you know you can hit what you
want there i want to feel healthy
that that same thing like you know you
can choose and then while i blank so
self-motivate improve my mood relax
sleep meditate you know you can
and then you can do whatever
combinations you want to be spiritual
you know here you have maybe you want
self-expression and so
um and what we're going to do right now
is we're going to play you
a frequency that happens now is there a
best
one that you want to start with in terms
of the three that you think is the best
um well you've got it on spiritual let's
let's boost our love
and okay so i want we so we have i want
to feel spiritual okay that's in the
oneness section so we've chosen that
then we have and boost my let's go to
love
okay so that's right here boom and then
yli let's go with relax
while i relax boom all right
so now what we're going to do is we're
going to play you guys
i'm going to play you guys the demo if
you can um brandon's recommendation
is to uh switch over to a pair of
nicer headphones if you had to have
phones the nicer they are the more
effective they'll be
um so ultimately
what happens with binaural beats is you
have one frequency playing in another
ear and a
second frequency playing in the other
and
when those frequencies cross through the
headphones in your brain
they create a third wave so if you've
ever seen a
or if you ever want to try this drop two
different size
pebbles into a body of water at the same
time and watch the ripples
bump into each other and then create
that third wave that third wave is the
binaural beat
and so it's so interesting it's such a
good analogy for it
yeah yeah the reason we need binaural
beats is because our brains vibrate
at frequencies lower than we can
actually hear
and so we can't play a tone that's going
to trigger
uh this is going to put us to sleep
because we wouldn't be able to hear it
but if you combine
two tones and create a third wave you
can make that third wave any size you
want
um it can have and when you can control
the size you can control the effect
and so the binaural beats are what
impact the
while i relax while i sleep while i
motivate because they can reach
um different patterns or different bands
of frequency
and the brain goes through what's called
a sympathetic vibration so
if an external source is vibrating at a
certain way your brain's automatically
going to vibrate at that same
rate so if you've ever seen like or been
to a concert or heard a noise that just
like drove you absolutely nuts you
didn't have a choice
that noise is just like not a healthy
noise and it's interesting talking about
healthy noises because
uh the entire music industry is tuned at
a frequency
that is somewhat disharmonious like
there are more harmonious
tones and notes that we could be using
on all of our instruments on everything
we listened to yeah
and that would be whoa ginormous so
basically the entire music
industry can shift more towards
harmonious
notes to be using love style notes
rather than ones that are maybe
dissonant
and that actually take us away from
coherence
yeah which that that's a huge thing if
we're talking a music industry that
impacts you know over a billion people a
day
um across the planet like that's a huge
deal
and then you get into you know the
psychology of we're talking about a lot
of words
when we're talking about you know sound
and color and the words associated with
them
these words have the same impact that
the sounds and colors do
and so we would need a linguist to
actually explain
the origin of sound and how they
correlate and what note
what what sounds get made when you say a
certain word
because um you know
yeah getting into a silly metaphor of
magic
magic is about casting spells that's
right and creating words is about
spelling
spelling that's right words are spells
so so what you say what you think it all
really matters
however as humans we have to we have the
ability to
take in what other people say like six
and stones can break bones but words
never hurt but
that's if you don't let the words hurt
yeah yeah and i think that you know for
a lot of people with media when you
watch
tv when you listen to songs you take
that as reality
and you believe those words and how
those people feel and what they think
and you if your brain is vibrating to
that it's taking it all in
it can't help but create that reality
and you have to
explore alternative perspectives in
order to overcome
those things so i wanted to create
something that could help people
you know take that step and realize that
they
um they have the control over their own
health if they want to control their own
thoughts yep yeah and we we talk about
this in
high-level perception in chapter 2 c
theory as like a neural real estate so
that
you're literally allowing into your
consciousness into your awareness
this input stream and for you to be very
vigilant about
don't allow that hate and allow that
love in and then also cascade out love
if these
sort of ideas can be proven at a deeper
level about
the person that goes to their plant
every day and says i love you i love you
i love you and that style intention
versus the one that's i hate you i hate
you i hate you and that style intention
and the different way that a plant would
blossom versus not just like a human
will blossom versus not yeah and so
that's the main
analogy in in the first part of of high
level perception
and so you know here we have set an
intention
like brandon's teaching you we're
setting
intentions and so in this case our
intention
again is set to feeling spiritual
boosting our love and while we relax
so again if you can have a nicer pair of
headphones here or if you want to
re-listen to this later
put on a nicer pair of headphones so
that you can actually hear this
and let's go ahead and do the demo
so here generating frequency and there
you go
you hearing it i'm hearing it beautiful
so um i've been meaning to answer your
question about the
difference between cellophagio and
schumann
so the selfiotones we talked about how
the monks use them
and they're good for emotional balance
and everything else
the schumann resonance was another
scientist who was studying
how um even like just
how bodies even out in space like the
size that they have their circumference
and and how they interact like they
essentially generate a frequency there's
a frequency like the earth vibrates at a
particular frequency
and he i think he did one of the studies
where
he took like a bunch of students and he
forced them to live underground
and he monitored how the behavior
changed
because they were not exposed to the
same frequencies as they would be above
ground super interesting
and so um essentially what he
what he describes are the different sort
of
frequency patterns that nature feeds off
of
so there's a 7.83 frequency that dna
seems to replicate off of so that's the
rejuvenation frequency that's on
euphoria
um the curel at one more time
so the earth vibrates at 7.83 hertz yes
this is considered
schumann resonance that's the schumann
residence ah okay
7.83 hertz yeah i saw that when i was
looking up
data on the i believe on the
electromagnetic field of planet earth
and the way that the solar
our sun interacts with it and the earth
is actually at 7.83 and you can actually
kind of tap into that as well and yeah
if you do tap into that then you have
potentially a little bit more like a
clear
channel or clearer uh antenna if you
will
uh that's rather than maybe being at
something that's not as
harmonic with the planet well you could
look at like lifestyles the
those that are living in nature those
that
um meditate with it and relax to it and
they feel better when they're in nature
because
everything in nature is growing at that
same
7.83 hertz that's impacting
its genetic existence so everything on
this planet
feeds off of whatever vibration the
earth has
and when i saw this on a documentary and
it was in a lab and they were showing
dna like replicating
i was like well clearly i need that for
my back problem and so
i i just had to explore it and
i don't think i'd be sitting here if it
didn't work
interesting so is the idea that if i
do undergo a binaural
beat at approximately 7.83 hertz my
my entire essence will tune into that
and that is at the earth's uh
same uh it's like the same uh
frequency essence of how the
how the plants actually blossom and how
the the sort of um
human that you said it's the actual
process of like cellular mitosis
like the dna replicating itself into so
you can actually
potentially birth the new cells that are
less
pathologized type scenario oh look at
look at
look at animals look at snakes look at
salamanders like the ability to
regrow lost limbs is something that a
lot of scientists believe that humans
should be able to do
and the reason we're not might have to
be i don't know is it based off
lifestyle is it based off like
because we have consciousness we might
not believe it so it's harder for it to
happen
um there's there's so many examples of
you know things in nature continuing to
grow
whereas humans have an expiration date
and so we have to evaluate like how do
we live compared to how do other things
live like
should we be living like elephants like
we my wife and i got to write elephants
on our honeymoon
and you know they talk about like if you
take slow steps if you look where you're
walking
you pay attention to the food you eat
yes like you you
you walk you take care of like your your
younglings like you follow them around
you teach them you let them explore like
all the things that elephants do are the
reasons they live longer
yeah and there's all things that humans
could do and we don't
and the ones that do live longer and
they live happier so that's uh
that's why i think we should be taking
more cues from nature yeah yeah
amen to that especially how we are
figuring out more and more how to do
that style of
in chapter 6 and high level perception
we talk about the ai coach
and how more and more we're going to
have a data fusion of our biometrics
and we're going to be able to retain
that youthful homeostatic capacity we
can take more and more of what nature
already does
and we can actually potentially leverage
like we took gfp from jellyfish and
channel rhodopsin from
algae and how we're uh potentially we
can even monitor more and more how to
uh be at more enlightened states of
consciousness that we can see in
animals and that that's a really
fantastic
idea i think it'd be helpful maybe if
for a moment
we turned up the v we stayed silent and
turned up the volume and let people
just tune in for maybe like 15 seconds
on it or something
let's okay let's do that enjoy here we
go enjoy guys
and so in order to do that you just you
just uh
you can either scroll down or you can
click that and so here you see that
we're doing
the feeling spiritual boosting our love
while we relax and
we're just going to turn up the volume
and stay quiet for you guys for a little
[Music]
bit
[Music]
you know it's so profound even just
tapping in for
just like 15 seconds and then you know
that
it's it's a really really helpful tool
you guys
did a fantastic job that's so good so
good
thanks let's um let's let's pause
we'll um so we're just really simple
what happens is when you
when you click the pause button you can
pause it
you can click play and put it back on if
you want to you can hit the button on
the left you can actually copy the link
and share the beat that you're listening
to so if you have a really good time
with that one share it with other
friends they'll get a link
they'll come download it and use the
exact same one if they already have it
they'll jump right to it
if you can get a little explanation
below about
why this specific frequency and you can
learn more
which is great for those that are more
inquiry-minded
that want to actually dive into some of
the science of spirituality at a deeper
level and then when you click this
x button what happens is you know you
see how long you were listening to
and you can give feedback so was that
helpful and then boom you just jump
right back
to the uh to that same uh home screen
that you saw earlier
and so now what we can do is since
you've listened to one we'll
probably play um at least one more after
we
look through the white paper probably a
good time to go through that now yeah
okay so uh essentially
over the past three years we've
accumulated
over 220 000 um sessions we just call
each time you press
play a session and we've monitored
how long people oh
i let me let me preface this first of
all like euphoria is an mvp
there aren't any profiles that you can
build on it yet
and so all the data that we have is
anonymous
i would need a data scientist to
extrapolate
my data out of there because i know i
use it a lot so you could probably pick
up on a trend
um however we have
anonymous data on 36 000 people that
downloaded the app
and they have the opt-in so um 220 000
times or more
people decided to choose whether they
liked what they listened to or they
didn't
and so out of all those sessions over 80
of the time uh people have said that
euphoria has helped them reach
their target state of consciousness and
so
wow yeah eighty percent of the time
people have said that it has to
help them reach that target state
exactly and that's that's in this
towards the
end those data points yeah should we
also show those or
later we'll get we'll get to it so it's
a big deal it's a big deal
that that's a you know that's showing
that the mvp is doing
yeah you know four out of five times is
huge yeah so
that those are metrics that we can build
a lot of confidence around
um so after we've done all that analysis
and we wanted to
explain to investors and to customers
and to scientists and researchers and
universities like
sound has so many
has so much potential to solve so many
of our problems um
on one hand if if our leaders
oh yeah or oh yeah it's mentally
balanced
in in chapter six and a i coach in the
second part on biometrics of awakening
i purposely spent the whole half of a
chapter
specifically talking about what happens
if the 2
200 billionaires 225 000
ultra high net worth the entire fortune
500 ceos the
u.s congress all of the u.n general
assembly
imagine if all of them we were able to
detect if they were living at
egoic levels of consciousness or or if
maybe
some of them are actually living at like
non-dual states of consciousness
and everything in between and how if we
at least had that data visualization
we could nudge people in the positions
of power towards
a lot of our problems may in fact just
be a go at consciousness in positions of
power i i feel like
egoic consciousness is the root cause of
our endless wars
like we have been at war forever um and
kind of like oblivious as to why and
i think that that's just that's just one
example
um but ultimately yeah if our leaders
were
you know mentally balanced and stable
and
all of us we all make decisions all the
time and if we make them
in a stressed state then those
choices aren't optimal you know
we we wind up suffering the after
effects of poor choices that we make
and so it's important to make choices
with as much consciousness as you can
in order to minimize the stress of the
repercussions
so i wrote this white paper in order to
start to shed light on why
more people can pay attention to sound
as a healing modality
there are lots of directions that that
this can go
but i wanted to start off by addressing
stress
because from our perspective stress is
the root cause of all of our chronic
conditions yes i haven't seen or heard
anybody say anything
contrary to that and so yeah our
approach
is to figure out how to navigate stress
i think stress can be good and you talk
to people who love stress stress like
gets
motivated and you know they want that
stress in their in their body when they
lift and it builds muscles so
you know stress is not a bad thing i
think when you talk about consciousness
labeling anything is good or bad is
kind of the problem and so it's more
about
recognizing what there's a healthy dose
there's a healthy dose that you know
that for balance
yeah for balance balance and for and for
the shadow birthing fire
and all these different types of things
yeah for sure healthy dose
yeah and so for me when i was in pain i
was living way below that threshold that
we saw on the other chart like a lot of
my emotions across all the colors were
just negative
and so the only thing you have to to
pull you up are the few things that are
that are positive and so i would listen
to euphoria
and shift the negative into positive and
slowly start to remove a lot of the
you know the things that were stressing
me out
um even just the perspective of you know
politics like
on one hand i stopped watching the news
but eventually it's just like
people are people we've all been in this
for a long time
we're trying to figure it out there's no
reason that
all of you know new york wall street and
dc
knows everything that we're talking
about right now
but what's important is that they want
to find ways of doing things better
and i think that there are people that
are
driving us in that direction um that are
in positions of power
and i think that they're the ones
listening to people like you
tell them and you tell them like where
their attention could be and how much
better would be for us
for everybody if their attention was
there that's right the guests that come
on the show are
the ones that i really do
feel like are the essence of
the future trajectory being guided to in
the most
benevolent direction possible in the
most flourishing
direction possible where every seed of a
human gets to
maximize its creative fruits in the
world
because it's possible it's possible and
it's our
evolution is very
clearly moving away from violence and
tyranny and malevolence more and more
towards
um prosperity and flourishing and
genius visionary entrepreneurs artists
leaders
and so when then the more awake we
become in terms of our
enlightenment and our progress towards
higher states of consciousness what
occurs is
we recognize that more and more and we
become in service to that
god consciousness to that christ
consciousness buddha allows a confucius
level consciousness
and that's when everything we do
butterfly effects out in the world with
that golden
yeah yeah let me get a fist bump for
that
that was that was perfect thank you that
was exactly
that's that's the truth and i think that
you know
um we talked about something earlier you
might want to preface it
but it was how um
you know there's a lot of different
cultures in society
and you know each culture is typically
structured around a belief system and
there have been belief systems that have
been around
this kind of information and and and
this you know i call it wisdom and sort
of connecting
with spirit spirituality at a higher
level um
and my experiences were driving me in
that direction
i you know it was it was the exploration
it was
looking up people like socrates and why
was he studying like the ancient
mysteries and what were those ancient
mysteries where did those
come from what were they talking about
yeah and you can't help but like dig
into
egypt and egypt talks about atlantis and
greek talks about atlantis and
what was going on there yes and and you
realize that there just
have been like obviously there's the you
know the buddhas and the jesuses and
all the real spiritual leaders that we
just know
like they're just everyday names but
there are a lot of people
who have had similar experiences to them
yeah and the information that they bring
that's right is
a big part of that like the truth about
the wisdom that
humans are are
are benefited to know that's right and
it's not
it's not secreted away we just needed
the internet
yeah we couldn't get there it's so
interesting
how in modernity there will be people
that take what can be at times six
months or a year or more
to try and sponge up all of the
profundity of those greatest states of
consciousness
and then they try and like anchor it in
civilization coming down from the
mountain
and so it's so interesting that when
that process happens
there's almost the the process of
consciousness
in a sense will attempt from in the
reflection as other people see that
there will be certain people that
recognize that and see that as such a
unique gift that they can like learn
from and
and whatnot without needing to maybe go
to the mountain themselves they'll just
take the experience that they can get
from that
from that anchor but then there's also
the people that
will stay so veiled and they will do
their best to say that
their gifts those aren't real those
states are
don't listen stay entrapped in the
economic machinery
keep you know keep being a slave in the
machine
and and so it's so important to
realize that those your nuggets of
wisdom your gold
that where you're sharing it with whom
you're sharing it with and
how you're sharing it and we have so
much data to unpack we should
yeah let's do unpacking so let's go to
the first maybe yeah okay so here's
okay yeah yeah so
you know there are a lot of things that
i wanted to talk about you know
proving this is kind of felt like
writing a high school paper where you're
just like proving
math problems and you know for us we had
to
touch on a lot of different aspects in
order to
uh you know bring this together but we
wanted to keep it really simple we want
to keep the app simple
we want to keep the conversation simple
um
but scientists and and investors they
want a lot of detail so
uh ultimately this paper was uh an
attempt to
simplify this mystery around the power
of sound so
um you know obviously we i think we've
been talking about the problem
uh about you know sort of where our
consciousness comes from
sort of how it's guided by the media um
which is essentially just saying like
you're asking
some guy who grew up in some house or
some woman who wrote some book because
she had some experience
and that experience also ultimately
becomes like your
your reality like the entire midwest was
the little house of the prairie
and we had no idea that a lot of the
stuff that's happening now
even existed there because for me
growing up like in south carolina
my world view was small so as i got to
brown university and expanded it
i i started to understand um just how
many different factors were in play
and so yeah we highlight um
you know just how just how much stress
has been
driving the health care system into
oblivion
and how the economy and everybody
individually is struggling as a result
of it
and so this has really been about how do
we
impact healthcare how can we talk about
um the importance of psychology
and addressing stress and how can we
like bring in new methods compared to
you know
what has worked on some level but we
clearly need something that's a little
more scalable to address
you know the the 70 of the population um
around the planet who
was struggling with stress before covid
i saw that
since coded um we've actually shot up to
about like
like the the spend on wellness has shot
up eight times
like people are desperate for solutions
just to feel
better an 8x increase in wellness
spending
yes wow yeah that's crazy yeah shout out
to the yang gang um andrew yeah yeah
yeah
for sure yeah for sure actually voicing
lots of
our most important yes yes moving
forward yeah
yeah um oh yeah and focusing on wellness
as like a biomarker basically yeah
exactly exactly exactly so from from me
like i
again graduated brown university with a
degree in business economics so
i kind of have melded my mindfulness
with my approach to
economics that's right and and really if
we can address
chronic pain like one a lot more people
make a lot brighter decisions that can
allow them to be more inclusive about
the entire
ecosystem that we live in like the
people um you were you
were talking earlier and that's what i
want to get to was um are you familiar
with esg
oh one more time on the acronym again
esg
yeah environmental social governance
environmental social governance yeah
yeah okay so that is about um
what corporations are doing to have a
more positive impact
on their environment the people that are
there yes and and the paths to
um you know manifesting the careers that
they're that the
employees want yes and so there's a huge
drive for this and it's something that
i'm passionate about and
we're seeing that companies that invest
more and the well-being of their
employees
yes ultimately improve their bottom line
yes yes there's exactly
the return on investment is 11-1 11-1
yeah according to duke
the duke aetna study um but more and
more more and more
data is coming out about how uh they're
reducing downstream health care expenses
at the business level
um for the individual for the family
unit
and even and the potential for an
insurance company to save a thousand
dollars
on every single one of their members
like that seven percent
the seven percent that they save is is
just
it just magnifies in terms of the number
of people that
they can save from having these
unnecessary
expensive readmissions to hospitals it's
just the systems that we have are so
there's just too many incentives moving
in too many different directions
and there's a lot of perverse ones and
the ones that are
you know shout out to vivian ming from
2000 and around 15 that introduced me to
the concept that you're talking about
right now which is that
all of these interventions towards our
maximizing our health and well-being
actually have massive compound
downstream effects in terms of
also financial yeah but you can you can
very simply
think about this like if you do get uh
bumped in the direction of not
having an explosive volcano on your
spouse
yeah and you trigger a healthier happier
night
you're actually going to perform so much
better the next day at work
you know your kids are going to be a lot
happier that night um you're going to
make healthier food decisions the next
day yeah i mean there's just ridiculous
amounts of
so the corporations actually
incentivized to
help your wellness with those bumps so
that you become
a better more holistic part of the yeah
the ecosystem of that company and family
and all this type of stuff so
spot on with that one i love that one
yeah so again um
the the basic structure of this paper
was to prove that to the individuals
who want to improve their own health and
well-being um
and also to the corporations who can
benefit from this by just paying a
little more attention and realizing that
you know it doesn't have to be
incredibly complex like
what i found is that there's so many
wellness solutions out there you've been
at trans tech there's so many ideas
and and and it's wonderful yeah um
and because there's so many ways to
shift your perspective
and you know i i had a lot of fun
growing up and i definitely used like
alcohol for that
like and and you have a good time
but we've i think individually and then
collectively we're going to have to look
at what are the side effects of the
things we're using
to feel better that's right and and so
is it
you know is it is it the toxicity in the
product or is it just our perceptions of
the product because
you like cancer is like unpredictable
people can smoke their entire lives
never get cancer
and people who smoke a little bit can
get cancer
my thought is that is it more of the
thoughts that people have
like i'm soaking this cigarette because
i hate my life versus
i'm really enjoying the cigarette and
this is the best part of my day like i
don't smoke cigarettes but
fair i'm not people do and and the thing
i'm using this to escape or am i using
it to heal and
and i think that i think that you know
when when you leave the
the dualistic consciousness and you
realize the benefits of unity
you know you can enjoy whatever you want
to enjoy you don't have to follow like
somebody else's list yeah you just have
to be aware and
recognize if if you're having a negative
impact on somebody else
yeah and and and as a person as me if
somebody else is having a negative
impact on me
it's my responsibility yeah to adapt and
say like why am i saying
yeah yeah and um yeah yeah and i take
that into
into the work that i do so um yeah we
designed this solution to be you know
we wanted it to be cost effective we
wanted to prove that we were being cost
effective
that this was something accessible um
adaptable
and and we want to create enough of it
so that way everybody can customize
their experiences there's 3500
combinations for people to choose from
on there
and we have we we have the potential to
add
we can double that and add a lot more so
um yeah getting into you know the
ultimate mission and purpose for
euphoria is
you know we believe that you know world
peace starts with inner peace
and i love that whoever whoever he meant
such a good one world peace begins with
inner peace
i love that that's so good and dalai
lama talks about that
many of the major spiritual traditions
have really voiced that
in the the inner world being a
reflection it
cascades out the peace in the outer
world as we do that yeah yeah and
and that's why i would you know take
these cues from my wife
or a friend or from an event and say
like is that
you know is this one of those signs it's
one of those things i need to pay
attention to is this
you know is this my exterior reflecting
my interior
even now i don't know if my kids are
watching but you know
when they do things and they say things
and
or or they're causing mischief and i
start to wonder is like
am i manifest are they showing me
something that i need to pay attention
to
not just about them but about myself
inside so much meaning that way too it's
so interesting
yeah and synchronicities and important
things well it's like all a lesson like
a lesson for them
and a lesson for you as a parent it's
like a lesson for so many things
unfolding i thought i was done with my
lessons
no no no no kids aren't yeah you got
somebody to go oh my gosh oh man
they don't stop until you know through
your whole life they they continue so
yeah they do and and and i appreciate
the lessons that they shared with me
um so yeah once once we sort of like dig
into
you know we talked about the sound
psychology and we start to explain sort
of
the elements that are going into
euphoria we talk about the binaural
beats the selfie of tones of human
frequencies
and and we can keep scrolling um
we wanted to you know this isn't the
most scientific paper
uh but we did want to at least explain
where we were coming from
um we do want to get into clinical
studies this isn't that's
a clinical study yeah but that's great
that is a priority for us
um as an entrepreneur who has yet to
experience
investors banging down their door um we
wanted to build a direct-to-consumer
product
again it's free we want to monetize it
but we want to figure out how to do it
so that way it's it's still available
and we have a good
idea on how to go about that um but
ultimately
we've uh you know we wanted to
prove um show people just like how
necessary this was i mean the stats on
how many people suffer i like that one
like 13
112 women began suffering
fibromyalgia after being exposed to 9
11.
like wow like in that study they
mentioned how they were either in new
york like essentially
they looked at a hospital saw an
increase in a particular
like malady and then wanted to figure
out was there a trauma tied to that
and so they interviewed all these people
and
i mean those numbers are astronomical
that's a hundred percent every woman who
had fibromyalgia
was impacted by 9 11 in that particular
study and so
it's it's it's really just sort of more
evidence that
our emotional reactions are really
dictating our physical health
yeah and that that is ultimately what
this paper is all about
is letting people know that if they want
to feel better
they have to think better or that is one
way is thinking better
can bring that relief and the importance
of shifting thoughts is
is one way to do that
um what else do we have
yeah so yeah i kind of just spoke to
that point
um yeah it's it's it's your
parasympathetic nervous system versus
your sympathetic nervous system um
anybody who's read you know the things
that i write uh
when you're stressed you're activating
sort of one side of your physiology
that's your sympathetic nervous system
that's supposed to help like you
mentioned fight or flight
and if you picture like you know being
attacked by a bear
you have two options you can you know
hug the bear and
and show that you're not scared um and
see how that plays out or you can run
away
um and you know just in this example
when you're running away
you are you know you pretty much shut
off your stomach so that way you can
save more energy you're not using it for
digestion
so you see that now in people how they
talk about
people who experience extreme stress
wind up having
sort of like these other other problems
like you know you have stomach issues
because you've been stressing out about
something and then all of a sudden you
need to
um you know follow other other steps um
sorry so yeah the 4a report is
again like we try to put out an annual
uh explanation for how people are using
the app
and we're able to build sort of uh user
profiles again it's based off the
actions that you can choose
but you know we're getting a lot of
people with insomnia saying like they're
sleeping for the first time in years
um we're getting that uh
it's like the most popular feature on
the platform
is sleep it's sleep interesting so
insomnia is that
yeah critical of a yeah when you and
if i didn't say it earlier the reason i
wanted to pursue things that could help
me sleep relax and meditate
were because all the science was saying
that people who have more of that
feel better that's right they they just
they're happier they're healthier
and so i've tried to unpack what it was
about sleep relaxation and meditation
that could do that
and when you get into that space you
start to understand like your body
recovers you have
more of these positive hormones that are
cleaning out your system
and when you and when you can keep your
body in balance especially emotional
balance
then you keep your system clean um and
people are having trouble with sleep
that's a really
yeah it's a huge thing and it's because
they're sleep because they're going to
sleep there they've got a million things
on people are
really like jamie wheel was on the show
and he goes people are excessively
ruminating in their default mode network
yeah that's a really great way to put it
because you have people
that have never practiced any kind of
meditation or mindfulness or any sort of
just
you know ability to calm themselves down
or peace or
joy or taking a breath taking the breath
and all of those do the similar style
process which is they help you go to
sleep and so if you've never
ever done any of those oh my goodness
you're just gonna be like
you're gonna tie yourself out to be able
to go to sleep yeah and you're gonna
wake up in the middle of night not be
able to go back to sleep
yeah kind of so many people in my life
that are struggling with this
and i feel like the one thing that i
still need to figure out is how do you
make headphones you can sleep in if
anybody's got that like yeah
the world needs it um because also train
yourself with the training wheels and
then be able to also get
yeah but yeah that's exactly the
training wheels of like being able to
sleep
i heard a there's a speaker in a pillow
is one of the things that people have
done there's like different yeah i
haven't tried that i knew a guy
who um nick if you're watching
um he was he he knew about those but i
never actually got to
have one and see it what it did but if
if that works can you connect your cell
phone to it because i want to know what
yeah yeah i want to know what euphoria
does to that pill oh and also there's
the pillow that
uh does the uh attempts to at least
begin doing eeg
analysis oh at the same time for that
which is crazy
and there's a there's a there's a also a
a uh vehicle
the headrest in the vehicle that oh
really
for your logic has that as well pay
attention have they figured out like why
cars are vibrating people to sleep
that's interesting too yeah
the frequency the frequency of the
vibration of the car um
there's a story about airplane pilots uh
fighter pilots
and they were told to adjust the dials
on the propellers on the sides
because each propeller was making a
sound and as that sound collides it
created a binaural beat
wow and so pilots were falling asleep at
the wheel so they started telling the
pilots
if you like avoid this frequency or if
you start to drill uh
you know get drowsy change change it to
a stimulating one yeah that kind of
stuff
so that's sleep and relaxing's popular
meditation
so the the funny thing about all of this
is that
there's a broad spectrum and there's
another chart that shows it but
people are using euphoria for all of
these things
nothing is more dominant than the other
like there's like more people are using
it for sleep
but um the mood improvers are like
a close fit um
and so in any case there is just
for me it proves that the app is doing
what it is supposed to do
and that's creating something for
everyone yeah so if you scroll down to
more
towards like the bottom of the white
paper we start getting into
like some of the statistics and um so we
went yeah so we went over
and high i highly highly recommend
people to
go through the euphoria white paper
again that uh
the link you can find right on um either
the euphoria
website or on brandon's linkedin either
so
check it out we can also put in the bio
but we went through that one
so here's you gave the number there was
thirty six thousand yeah international
participants
so for for the investors that we're
talking to um those spikes
and for other entrepreneurs that might
be watching this
um being uh susceptible to
influencer marketing if anything it just
shows you that there's a method that
will attract people
um and influencers are clearly one of
those if anything you don't want an app
where
influencers don't get you those spikes
so again we're fundraising so we can
afford the influencers to get more of
the spikes
um and that's by the way that's another
big pillar of our ethos here in los
angeles is that once we sort of build up
this in a sense this ethically aligned
team of especially influencers as well
is that we want to be able to do things
like basically plug
epic people like brandon and euphoria
into them and say that guys
this is something that's so deeply
ethically aligned there's either you
know no cost or
you know that's the kind of ideas that
we have here
so there's a lot to get behind us with
so if you are
doing more well off on the twitter
sphere instagram sphere tick tock sphere
youtube etc reach out to us simulation
series
gmail.com get plugged into our
influencer ecosystem so we can do the
style of promotions
they're crucial i mean our business
model is
spreading well-being and spreading
wellness and we're setting
up you know the next phase of our
business to help other people do the
same
so that's spreading wellness that's
another really good one bro
yeah so whether it's an influencer who
wants to spread a good vibe
or a company who wants to you know give
access to a product
or or a platform that wants to optimize
for um well-being using sound and color
and light
whether it's a digital platform or
physical one like that's the euphoria
business model
we can create a combination um of sound
and light and color
that can shift people in positive
directions
so we want to help others to help
the people that they want to help their
customers their followers their family
members themselves
have you have you thought in terms of
the
we'll get to the evolutions of this but
in terms of playing
on the screen while the binaural beat is
happening the
ocean or the waterfall or the rainforest
these types of things and like
where does that rank in terms of like we
can do the proper
a b testing and and see if the
scientific evidence again clinical
was very very important but yeah you get
there yeah yeah
it's it's um i guess you're asking more
as like what is
uh like are we looking to research the
benefits of those types of like natural
sounds as well
and visuals visuals visuals yeah visuals
yeah
yeah binaural plus potentially some
birds chirping or bird or plus ocean
waves
and then yeah the visual as well these
are all maybe interesting fusions of
well yeah if you take a like a product
like calm um
where people can sort of like you know
create that uh
audio um environment for themselves um
the thing with the wellness space is
that it's kind of
easy to copy everybody and
and so it's true that's a good point and
and you know i worked on wall street and
so i've seen what competition does and
you know it's fine it's it's how our
economy has evolved and there's a lot of
benefits to it
however uniqueness is very important
yeah and uniqueness and we talked
earlier about like you know the
intellectual property around things and
how
if um you know we're basically just
trying to like
confine consciousness to say that only
some people are allowed to have access
to it
and i get that you know that's important
on a business level however we want to
figure out a way
to share what we have but keep our
approach sustainable
yeah spread a wellness without borders
with high data interoperability but keep
it sustainable so that it can continue
growing and flowering
yeah so one of the one of the thoughts
we have was to work
with companies.com to make our platform
more algorithm-based something that can
be licensed out by a company like
calm to um increase the effect of the
of the experiences that people have on
that platform yeah so yeah we could add
a bunch of nature sounds and and we kind
of want to
um but we're going to give khan the
chance to work with us first
and down the line it seems like this is
very much so going into that
that indistinguishable virtual reality
immersive haptic
environment where i'm just literally
just going
and yeah in you know ambisonics i'm
in full haptic i'm in yeah
complete just that'll bring it back
melting into the ocean
yeah exactly that's like super futurism
and i love that stuff and it's not even
that far we could get there and
if we really tried we could get there in
10 20 years but we're
we're we're very much in a lot of
different places as a civilization yeah
honestly i think that you could apply
that approach to
professional athletes now that's right
and there's a market for that which
you're spot on yeah
is that the athletes need the peak
performance recovery periods
to be like just now just right into the
yeah exactly yeah that's a really good
point and that's how to actually get
the fuel financially to actually get to
the 10
to get to the goal in 10 years rather
than it taking 30 because there's no
fuel no financial incentive
yeah so that's really interesting you go
into the market and then the market
helps because you found the niche where
the market will actually pay for it
and then that democratizes the
technology to the rest of the population
boom yeah and that's that's kind of what
wellness is doing
um they're not getting the support from
the health healthcare industry
and so they're we're kind of in a place
where we're creating the preventative
healthcare industry
and again it's not about competition
it's about the fact that
without cooperation we have to create
and we'd rather create
with cooperation so yeah you know i've
had conversations with
you know professionals who work at
hospital systems and if anything was
just an education on what their
motivations are
and realizing that you know our
motivations are not currently in
alignment
and if anything we can build the
wellness industry to be very attractive
to the healthcare industry
which leads to m a down the road however
if they never catch on
and recognize that there's an 11 to 40
year window
where they're not treating um
the mass population then you know
they're just going to miss the boat
yeah because people are about
preventative health right now it's
necessary
yes yeah and you guys you mentioned this
we had the
the massive numbers of submitted
responses this is what we did at the end
we hit the like button
yeah exactly so when you hit the like
button we're basically analyzing what
did you listen to how much did you like
it or or how long you listen to it um
if you liked it and and you can see like
that distribution is not
drastic you know if you look at the left
those are all the likes
and then the counters to the right um in
the first chart
are essentially the nose and oh actually
now this is a different chart
so if anything we're seeing here that um
vitality is just slightly more popular
than focus
but when we when we dig in deeper you'll
see that the people that are using
vitality
are quick listeners like they're the
people who are
more about you know quick responses um
they want
the more the physical motive physically
motivated listeners
um but then focus you get into the more
the cerebral
individuals willpower um you know i use
that a lot because
you know you just you just have to be
confident there's no alternative when
you're trying to manifest something
positive
um and so this biofeedback this one is
more reflective of how
you know 80 of the people that listen to
it like it and it's across
all of the different scenarios it's not
you know people like one thing and not
the other
it's all sort of relative so if you look
at um what is it uh
positive oh yeah like um mood
improvement versus meditation
um like they're not used as much as the
others but it's still relative to the
number of no's that they get like we
don't get a lot of negative no's on
meditation
um and so if anything it's just the
consistency
i think that the conversation that i've
had with people
some people really love it some people
just want just need a few
tweaks um for us to make in order to
love it as much as everybody else
what was their feedback for the tweaks
that they want
um so some people want the higher
register everything on euphoria higher
register
yeah everything on euphoria is currently
at the gamma level oh yeah
oh i see and some people want like
higher frequencies than gamma yeah
that's but can the human get yeah
yeah well i don't know consciously if
there's like a higher level
but people have a preference for a
particular tone level
so if anything like i like bass and
that's what the gamma range is
oh it's more bass it's it is the bass
range it is the bass range yeah
okay and but gamma but does that trigger
the gamma brainwave
frequencies oh it does that is that
correlated that
that's what you're trying to say is that
this higher
higher hurt it was like a couple hundred
hertz yeah so if you
use like like the way or um self edgios
listed
uh like 396 hertz is like the root
chakra
frequency um you could listen to that
at 396 hertz or you could listen to it
at 449.5 hertz
okay it'll have the same effect but some
people rather listen to it
actually no i don't know if it has the
same effect it'll have the same effect
emotionally but when you listen to
something in the gamma range it improves
your focus focus
and so you can add a layer of focus to
whatever you're listening to
and so that's what euphoria is you want
your
mind to focus on getting to that
positive state of mind yes
and that's what i know gamma can do and
is there also
euphoria hasn't went into um
getting people into like the delta
states of mind or the theta
or the alpha states has it
so when you create a binaural b you can
establish let's show
let's show what this uh what this looks
like
so what's the best
okay so all right so
just using this example spirituality
it's up here at like your crown chakra
and
let's let's scroll down let's scroll
down to the heart chakra let's go to
green
and let's go oh go to here yeah
harmonious
let's go with harmonious okay um
so the thing is is that shift from
anti-social critical
jealous demanding to empathic
compassionate balanced forgiving
yeah if we can we can choose like either
hopeful or compassionate for this
particular example are you hopeful
and what do we want to boost uh let's
boost our uh rejuvenation because then
we'll talk about schumann in there too
oh cool okay so rejuvenate the bottom
one
oh that's schumann that's the 7.83 guys
get pumped that's the planetary one and
then and then uh we have schumann and
then
rejuvenation and while we let's go with
uh let's go with um
meditate something happy in the middle
okay so i want to feel hopeful
and boost my rejuvenation while i
meditate yeah let's
let's so the psychology of that yeah
that's psychology of sound again
yeah sure should do you should we let's
listen for like 20 seconds and then
yeah okay okay let's do it okay guys
it's coming
here you go get your headphones ready
[Music]
[Music]
okay interesting so
that was
that was our where we we were doing
um the heart
okay and we were doing
um
was it which one did we pick one
rejuvenation nation
okay there it is how are you feeling
it was so it's become the trigger has
become fast enough to where
it's just like maybe an inhale or two
and it's like it's really starting to
feel
really strong and um it's really nice
for people to
to to check it out at home and yeah and
and give it a go themselves with some
nice headphones
yeah that's a it's a strong one yeah the
um
i guess there's a few things i i guess i
could say the first thing is the next
time i come i i'm gonna need some
headphones
first of all get your [ __ ] together with
two pairs of headphones
i'm i'm trying to channel your vibe
because i can't hear it the way
everybody else can
um but with that particular combination
um i want to sort of explain like what's
going on so
let's just say that it was a few weeks
ago and um
the election was happening if you were
stressed by it you know
you're reaching out for hope you're
hoping for something regardless of which
side you're on the
hope was there and you know struggling
with something like hope or or feeling
negative about it
is probably going to bring you know
feelings of negativity like in your
chest area whether it's your heart your
lungs
whether your your breath your breathing
erratically
um i i would be curious with the either
global human resonance or or a
collective like hrv
says uh about how people felt during
that point in time
um but ultimately uh so what you can do
is
start to vibrate that particular part of
your body
back into its more naturally a neutral
state
because if you're in a neutral state
that's that's better than being stressed
out
negative and for me i've actually tried
to force myself positive and that just
created more stress
and i've just found a lot more pleasure
and balance
so um being able to
bring that erratic behavior back into
balance you bring sort of like peace and
ease to that part of your body
um and when you use rejuvenation like
you've one you've brought the sound to
this part of you
and then you add rejuvenation into that
and so
you've got this extra pattern happening
to where we're bringing it back into
balance but we're fusing it with that
same energy that the earth uses to help
everything else regrow
and so you can bring that rejuvenation
to the parts of your body that
are in pain and you can start to heal
you know
what's what's not in accordance with
your best health what's
not in ease what's dis-ease as as
everybody likes to say
so i think dis-ease the diseases that
we're all suffering from
um can be treated by what can bring them
back into ease
yes yeah perfect that's right
spot on for that one i agree yeah
i think i think like so knowing that and
the people that
have gravitated to the app or largely or
a lot of them are somewhat aware of you
know chakras and energy and emotions
um we get some people that have never
heard of any of it and they use it for
their colder their flu and they and they
got better
and so um again like you can see here
that bliss was the number one thing that
people wanted uh
most of um you know shout out to my mom
she was probably the first one that i
talked to who gravitated toward
listening to bliss every time she went
to bed
and when she woke up it was it was like
the best morning she ever had like every
time
and she's taking breaks from it you know
as as life moves on
and she just emailed me recently saying
that um
you know she she you know work it's
challenging
and and during covet with remote working
she works with a lot of um a lot of
individuals who
you know aren't younger who use
technology all the time and
they're a little bit more stressed out
with like having to work in this kind of
environment
and so it's just a lot of it's a lot of
stress on an individual
and a corporate system and everybody
else so you know knowing that
i was able to like get her back into a
better place
to function and to work is you know
testament to
you know what sound can do yeah so i
you know i'm happy being a facilitator
of sound but sounds way bigger than
anything i can put together so
i'm just trying to understand it and
share it in the most positive way that i
can
spot on i i i'm a big fan of bliss on
tap as
well especially i'm hitting bliss a lot
yeah
yeah and so we're starting to develop
sort of like character traits
so we've got our power listeners um
and they're you know the power listeners
the people that use it the most they
tend to listen to it in spurts of like
uh
like the eight minutes um or sorry no 30
minutes
uh whereas i need i need a closer view
of that myself
but um we're seeing that like uh you
know
the three things that jumped out the
most for people gravitating to sleep
they listen to it for about eight hours
at a time that's that's the heavy bulk
of the users
uh the power users they use the app the
most um however they tend to use it in
like 30 minute spurts to sort of say
this is the mindset that i need to get
into right now and i want to listen to
it before a meeting before i work
out um so a lot of different scenarios
there
and then the other heaviest are the
one-minute users now
there's there's two ways that we can
look at this and and that's the blitz on
tap
oh that's a funny one for bliss on tap
yeah
yeah
to just tap in quit yeah yeah and so
people are just um
they're just jumping in and you know at
first i wondered if it was just people
um clicking into it for the first time
and listening and then canceling but
there's so many people
that seem to use this pattern over and
over again
like they're just quick hit bliss quick
his vitality quick hit rejuvenation
and and then that's and they're good to
go and that's what we were talking about
regarding that sort of catalog of
of immersive virtual worlds that are
indistinguishable that we can tap
into for healing for athletes or for
rejuvenating for people that are doing
creative work yeah and it's super
automatable
um if that's a word yeah yeah because
you know we're we're working on a few
things with uh you know we're taking
these algorithms and we're applying them
to more real-world scenarios
and one of the projects that we have is
called hwell and uh
my co-founder ben simon thomas on this
um
he's been wonderful to work shout out
shout out i mean like ben
big ben big ben big ben shout out love
ben thank you battery for you
yeah um yeah so he's been working with
us and
we've been able to like design these
algorithms that uh it can
essentially like if you just put your
phone in your pocket
and it just listened to like the words
you use or or
really interesting or it analyzed your
text messages that you send out
or or what you're doing on social media
or the articles you read the content you
watch like
we're building algorithms that can score
the subconscious impact
of media content i love that and so it's
really about
how enlightened are you i just i just
i just straight up that's the question
that's where i always go with this kind
of stuff like
i have so many hypotheses i just posted
like a couple like a week or so ago that
i think that
likely the the higher use of the
prayer emoji and the heart emoji is
probably higher states of
consciousness oh yeah that's definitely
worth pursuing so is it worth pursuing
and
that's gratitude gratitude if you're if
you're receiving those
sorts of of like click-baity aggressive
hatred-driven
hit pieces um you're likely of a lower
you know you got to archive that those
codes and go to the higher
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's a really
useful insight that kind those kind of
algorithms i love that we should
we should talk about that maybe you and
ben both come on and we can unpack that
that could be a fun one to to do
absolutely and that could be another
huge benefit to you for you as well as
seeing that kind of data well as an
entrepreneur it's like we
it would be great if we could just like
launch euphoria as like you know the
next headspace or calm
um yeah but the process to do that you
know it looks like headspace and column
like blew up overnight right but
but it's a five year ten year like you
never know how long always journeys yeah
and so we feel that until we get to that
status
you know we're proving our case we're
building the products that we can we're
collecting
revenue or investments however we can
and we'll get to that point totally so
for
for me it's you know that drive of like
you know the sooner sooner this happens
the sooner that happens
but ultimately um it's just about being
flexible so if
what we're doing with well takes off
before what we're doing with euphoria
like we're still applying the same
concept age well
age yeah like getting older oh a g e h
well oh yeah yeah so it's a platform to
help um
aging adults yeah uh one
find product solutions and concepts
about wellness that can help them with
their individual
lives we can sort of help you know if uh
if you were to text us and say
you know i woke up this morning feeling
like these kind of things then we could
recommend
tvs like tv shows movies books articles
exercises to help them improve their
balance
or their emotional balance and that can
be
done by them through technology it can
be done by their caregivers and then the
only technology that
aging adult needs is just a sms text
message
so if they can handle text messaging we
can tell them all the things that
can improve their day and as they
experience less days with stress they
get less of all the chronic conditions
that's right
i was saying earlier um i think it's 80
of people over 65 have at least one
chronic disease again that's incubating
over 11 to 40 years
so they already have it and now we're
just tracking it at 65.
and then 68 of those people have two
diseases and comorbidities are what's
driving
the health care industry and like into
apparel because
insurance companies are like why do you
guys keep asking people to come back
more and more so now
it's all about how do you actually get
people better and proving
that they are getting better and and
minimizing all these like
compounding like ailments that people
struggle with
yeah so you're speaking again on the
kind of vivian ming
maximizing life outcomes language again
just that it's so
interesting to to take something as
simple as an sms for someone around the
world whether it's someone that's older
and can only handle that
or whether it's someone that only has
the device that enables just the sms
around the planet in lower socioeconomic
status
yeah how interesting it is for them to
get those tiny notifications that
maximize their health
and wellness and life outcome and we're
suggesting low tech and no tech
solutions so
it's not about something expensive that
they can't access it's about
remembering to breathe remembering to
take a walk outside yes
remember like find out what what
inspires all
within you like what is that
inspirational thing
and we want to help them track it and we
want to remind them as often as they
want to be reminded
of the things that can help them feel
better and give them the agency to
choose the path that they want to take i
think that a lot of us are on this
journey
with zero clue about what tools there
are for us
and we google it and i i'm a googler it
took me five years
to learn everything that they didn't
teach me in school
because i couldn't travel to ancient
greece and like get it firsthand i
couldn't go to egypt
so we learned through the internet but
ultimately um
you know it's it's applying it and
seeing what works and seeing how it can
um incorporate into people's daily lives
uh and and
i'm the biggest user of it you know i
wanted to to feel better and to
operate at a higher level so um the fact
that 80 percent of the people who
download this app still have it
is for me that just says that you know
we're doing the right thing
and and sound is powerful yes
including myself and several friends as
well this is
that's how you do it you get people that
love what you do and then they
stay with it because it's it brings them
value yeah so the testimonials are
as a business leader i need a better
system of collecting those testimonials
we'll get to that um but ultimately i
mean i think the first
person that i heard from uh she used
euphoria
to help her with chemotherapy um and
she knew that sound was beneficial i
think
i don't know if she was a sound healer
she might have gone to sound baths and
knew that they had benefit but to have
something that you could take
um into a you know hospital or or
you know doctor's office that allowed
her to manage her pain
and then even when she was done with
chemotherapy she was still using
euphoria
to sort of like rebalance everything
that she had gone through
yeah so between those and the
infographic about the guy who's using um
using the wearable and tracking all this
data like
it's it's just all evidence that you
know sound is healing
and and i it's like how many different
ways i have to say it
[Laughter]
that's right yeah brandon brandon's
email is also in the
bio below if you guys want to get in
touch for any
collaborations um download the app use
it
we're collaborating with um with uh
mexico and designing um
a sound-based sauna and building uh
working with life rhythms and robert
alexander he's uh
composing music using the self edgio
scale
and we're distributing that to spas
around the world
so we're all about collaboration um
we're working with some virtual reality
companies and they're designing like
meditation games
in virtual reality and we are again
helping them improve sort of the the
method of
augmenting experiences through sound yes
to promote to promote well-being it's
all labs are so awesome
because you know you have some other you
know great data visualizations about
some of the horrible chronic illnesses
that are plaguing our world and just the
ways that we must
focus on wellness and well-being to
really maximize our
our health and our happiness and our
flourishing and our gifts and all this
kind of stuff
yeah i mean a lot of those problems are
psychologically driven
and it's the environment that we live in
and we need more
people explaining that we live in an
environment
with the potential to be way better than
it is and
we just have to make the individual
choices to pursue that and you know
my business will drive that direction as
long as i'm at the home and
you know we're doing as much as we can
for as many people as we can so long as
you know as long as we can it's we just
need the resources
i'm sure you're familiar with that
perspective yeah yeah
so yeah there's many different ways yeah
like
yeah getting getting to the business
model page if anybody wants to reach out
so
obviously right now you can download the
app for free um we are looking to
you know enhance the app so it is more
engaging and it is something that people
will
sort of recognize the value of um and
subscribe to it
because it'll offer features that allow
you to track your health and well-being
see the benefits of it and recognize
what is really helping versus what might
not be
um that's that's the direct-to-consumer
approach for businesses
we are designing these algorithms and we
want to make them available for other
people to put them on their platforms i
mean if you imagine a
you know we talked about com you can
imagine even spotify
if spotify could augment the song that
you're listening to
to be healthier then you could do that
through spotify and i don't have to
create a music player platform yeah yeah
however and that's the licensing
approach that we want to take however i
do
see that music is that valuable and if
we don't get that
relationship um then you know we'll
probably build it ourselves but it's the
same thing with google
it's it's you know we can filter the
internet to
help people find what's healthier versus
what's harmful i love that one that
one's a
huge one that i align with a lot yeah
yeah and then on the higher corporate
level
enlightenment level not on the political
left versus right level on the
enlightenment level
yeah yeah and so with with uh
partnerships like if you wanted to
you know distribute uh euphoria to your
customers or your employees
um if it needs to look like it's on your
platform white labeling
is what we're talking about there and
then all the analytics you know
human resource professionals are and
caregivers
are trying to help people without
knowing exactly how they feel or what
they're going through and they have to
sit down with them and get those
conversations going to understand and
maybe send out a bunch of surveys and
analyze it that way
and what we want to do is create a
system that allows them to
see the data live knowing that
all right some corporate announcement
just went out everybody's like
really down about it what do we need to
do as a company to get everybody back
positive
we're seeing a lot of sick days and
that's what companies are going through
like 300
or billion and revenue lost due to sick
days like
one the people some people are sick
because their
immune systems are shot because they've
been thrown through so much stress
um you know and and some people just
need a
a a break they need it for just you know
just uh just rebalance that's right and
so i think
again if we can catch things further
upstream
then we can start to balance things out
in a way they don't seem so
like world shifting like it's okay to
let people work from home now we know
that
like it's okay to let people like take a
healthy day or to
take a mini break in the middle of their
work day and these are things that it
came about because
kovit has pushed that conversation
whereas the wellness industry was
paying attention to it years ago yeah
interesting so there's a lot of really
good data
in here there's the yeah
the team's super supportive um you know
they've been
giving me the advice similar to you you
guys have knowledge i don't have
and and that's how i build my team
around the skill sets i that i
i lack and i like to surround myself
with people that can
um advance me so uh nardo's got great
experience coming from
uh kaiser uh gwen is i mean
she is she's the toughest toughest
individual possibly that i've met like
she is she's a strong person
um and there's there's way more i want
to say but i don't want to upset her
but she's awesome um and vlad has been
my friend since um
since school uh we both graduated from
brown
and he was our first investor he has
experience in the
medical device space he's that's been
his entire career he's worked for
companies that have excelled and
companies have um
you know exceeded their limitations in
the whole nine yard and
nine yards and he's helped me to
recognize what
what the industry needs in order to
allow us to make that shift all three of
them are helping me make that shift from
a wellness platform to a medical
solution
because it can be and there's so many
things we can do
and we just have to take the necessary
steps to get there
wow sounds like a fantastic team as well
and then
like i feel like we have a good amount
of stuff that we covered do we have
other assets that you know that
um that i think that's pretty good right
yeah
yeah i got through everything yeah if
anything people might need to take a uh
watch this in in spurts i don't know if
we if we tell them too much or what
but yeah this is this is just the one
pager um
for entrepreneurs out there it's just
another you're going to create a lot of
documents you're going to have to send
them out to a lot of people
you're always going to be summarizing
your results and your stats
and and and pitching your product um
it's an inefficiency i guess or or at
the same time it's
you know an evolutionary thing where you
really need to prove something
for uh for people to have that
confidence so
also a way to make this more algorithmic
so that you can generate the data from
uh yeah from algorithms so that and
design it in a way that you just kind of
like
do reinforcement learning with training
the algorithm over time to
sort of uh like tinder cards decide
what's the best design what's the most
optimal way to show the data
yeah and the stuff with algorithm
evolution i for me it's important that
it's done in a way where
everybody that's involved with it
it's like you want to make it unabusable
it's like you want to
minimize the risk of what people can do
with
your products or what happens to them so
again we want to even add more
communication so that we can understand
our community even better
um so that's also a big thing that our
our current customers have asked for
like there's a strong desire to have a
community where you can talk about
emotions and not feel weird about it
yeah yeah yeah and that's another good
thing that boas gaon and wisdo have done
is they've
they've went through the process in
building
out wisdom in israel and now it's all
around the world
500 000 plus people are using it and and
yeah people are now able to talk to
other people that have went through
the difficult life processes and it
creates that community and so
people really want also a kind of
synthesis of things
like euphoria with wisdom like you were
saying with spotify with
like a google enlightenment style like
ranking of things like all this type of
stuff so
there's a huge huge synthesis among us
in that space and
um i think we did a really solid job
breaking down
a lot of the euphoria white paper and
and also the psychology of sound in
general
um there's a couple things that i still
think are important to talk about i mean
we talked about this a little bit before
we started and i think it's really
important it's probably important enough
to
to mention um on the way out as much as
we can
if we can just mention that
when it comes to underprivileged
communities
and helping them is that it's really
important to come in and ask questions
about what their needs are
first and then i really appreciated your
perspective about having a hackathon
for their solution that's like a cool
way to crowd source innovation
yeah for a solution and then you said
then we
introduce things that they don't have
and they get to pick what they want from
that buffet basically
and then we build business models around
what they demand
and then we can get uh people involved
that are like the higher net worth
people as patrons into that
style of of assistance and so i really
appreciated that style of thought and
underprivileged communities
i mean we talked a lot about the way
that kind of the future of
of these sort of correlates of more
enlightened experiences
and just people over time becoming more
and more
integrated with a sort of ai coach some
sort of a feedback
system that happens with themselves
achieving better longevity
better uh moment to moment health
happiness flourishing
more and more of their north star
pursuits
so i feel like some of the stuff that i
wanted to
ask you at the end we'll we'll we'll see
what
we can hear from you in the time that we
have left on the show
on these topics but just a quick
bit i want to hear what you think
is even the nature of consciousness and
reality
my answer um
consciousness to me is
an exploration um
it's like something that exists
and at the same time it can evolve
but it always feels like it's in
evolving into something that already
existed
and so that's i guess that's my way of
saying like to me consciousness is
everything
um i tried to upload another photo for
you um
somebody took an image of the solar
system
and it shows like these two like bubbles
one above it and one below it and
there's
people out there who talk about um
how consciousness started as like a
single thing and then it branched into
two
and it kind of mitosis itself
into all these different stages of
consciousness
and um and how we're living in the third
which is more like in the middle
and so there are experiences and
and essentially there's just like wisdom
that's feeding us
down here and it's it's like it's all
the experiences that have sort of
created the universe
but at the same time like there's a
piece of consciousness within each of us
and
it's allowed to be unique and it's
supposed to be unique
and i think that
it is what drives people and and for me
it's like this like
tiny little energetic magnet that's
inside of everybody
and our consciousness draws our
experiences to us
even if we think the experiences are
just happening
and again that's about how you know this
quote from gandhi is how
a few people have said it but you know
our thoughts lead
to um our thoughts lead
to our words our words lead to our
actions our actions
lead to our habits our habits create our
beliefs
and our beliefs create our thoughts so
we're in a cycle
consciously and we have to
for me you know the reason the whole
purpose of euphoria is to
help people recognize if that's not
working for them
and how to make it work for them
because for me it's all about people
trying to manifest the lives that they
really want
the the lives that they believe they're
capable of having
and the challenges that they face
are because of other people who came
before them who were not thinking about
them
and i want systems that think about
everybody into the future
yeah seventh generation principle yeah
yeah i didn't know that existed but
that's that's a great place for me to
start likewise yeah
that's why what we're architecting right
now and building is very much driven by
that style of what we want the future to
look like that's more
beneficial yeah and that's that's why i
talk about how
we need to get the insights of the
people who are going through the
struggles because
it's not about us designing i mentioned
this after watching the the
social dilemma it's not about the five
people in california who are creating a
solution for people around the world
the better solutions are going to come
when we understand what the people
around the world need need
yeah that's right yeah and that's the
ori brothens
starfish also in a decentralized way is
that you have to get the data at the
edge
facebook and it's all these big tech
giants they're not actually getting data
points from people
at the edge that are actually the ones
that are experiencing what they need
in their communities and there's no
feedback loop back to the corporate
so that's the hierarchy versus the flat
decentralized
process that would enable that type of
feedback
i appreciate your thought on um
consciousness as well i would
i would generally agree and that
that well the point is for me was that
it was we're un were exploring infinity
and that we're we've been doing that
we're going to continue doing that
that our godhead is recursive we're
entering into the metaverse soon
and that you know
if you want to it's like
do your absolute best to guide the
trajectory of
the of the planet away from the fermi
filters that are
trying to impede the process of of
reaching the godhead and that's
you know that starts with like you also
mentioned it starts with the inner
work that starts with the work on one's
own consciousness one's own awareness
and driving that more towards those god
consciousness states and butterflying
that out
and then we can more easily get to our
next explorations of that
infinity so yeah that's that's been a
fun way also non
the non-dual oceanic marrying that with
the
individuation and the in the unique
artistry
so it's a very symphonic symphonic like
all one oceanics
symphony but also individual unique
artists that are contributing
some sort of melody or instrument that
we're playing
and so it's kind of marrying it's very
much so marrying east and west
it's very much so like that and i think
it's actually really helpful
potentially moving forward in the future
because there is
a little bit too much uh kind of
non-dual melting into the ocean and then
kind of like
in a sense like not that important to do
sdg stuff not that important to
to do maximizing health and well-being
for for people
and so that's something that i found
very interesting but there's also a lot
of
individuals that focus on just the
individuation and
never tap into the self-realization
of the non-dual and if they don't do
that then they're not acting from the
god consciousness as well
so there's a balance there yeah i think
it's it's
it's a longer story than we have time
for but sort of how
the concept of god consciousness or
unity consciousness
um is introduced
to to cultures and civilizations and
societies
that's right it's it's if
the day that we have time to talk about
sort of like who teaches that message
and why they taught it and where they
had to teach it
and and what they were up against i mean
the story is
beyond fascinating and and i think that
you know we can but the way we're
exploring it now is just
indicative of how valuable consciousness
is
you know it's it's driving our health
it's driving our economy it's driving
the way we live it's driving our
experiences
and you know if something else gets
prioritized over that
um you know is it
is is it just ignoring like the masses
while it benefits the
the few um we just we just got to get it
to where it's
everybody benefits there's there's our
scenarios where everybody wins yes yes
yes the nash equilibrium
it's a very very important concept in in
game theory to truly embody the
individual can make decisions that
benefit themselves and the collective
simultaneously in a
maximal omni-win scenario
it's crucial um and spot on to we will
when we get to unpack in our next rounds
we will get to dive deeper into
specifically this
that we've mentioned several times that
why is it that
where in the especially western
education system is there ever a
conversation about unity consciousness
or god consciousness
i was never introduced to that uh in
myself in the education system
and most people that i know even if they
go through the highest levels in the
university system
are never introduced to it and that's
extremely worrisome and that's why
people feel like cogs in the economic
machine
instead of like the divine beings that
they truly are
and so we have a lot of work to do in
that regard at younger ages but
maria montessori the montessori method
is pretty good for now following the
child's pretty good and there's
there's a lot of other i went to
montessori school maybe that's it
that's probably why you're more
actualized essentially seriously
and that's probably going to be really
important for your two kids as well
yeah this is yeah there's a lot there's
a lot here
yeah i need to talk to you about that
one yeah i don't need to switch my kids
to montessori right now
yeah there's a lot to unpack there and
yeah there's a lot there's a lot there
cool some silly things yeah i like to
ask some silly things on the show
um at the end um the first question is
do you shower in the mornings or at
night
more at night more at night more often
at night but
it's more like event based like now that
i have two kids
yeah it's more like uh yeah i'm a bit
dude for a shower
so like today i took one right before i
came yeah and that was the afternoon
so okay so vary sometimes but yeah i
wouldn't say that um
i'm at liberty of following any level of
strict routine because of the two kids
and
craziness with that yeah so what about
when you when you are in the shower are
you a
like a shampoo conditioner body wash
person do you use all three of those do
you only use one of those do you use a
bar
soap would use a loofah yeah so i think
it was um
after i started losing all my hair i
decided to start shampooing and
conditioning more
um so yeah you know it's
my head will itch if i if i don't so um
shampoo conditioner my wife has gotten
away from the plastic bottle so now like
i'm getting these bars that show up in
paper and yeah yeah
you know they're they're working so i'm
happy about that yeah no i'm a washcloth
guy
my wife and i we joke about that it
might be a black thing um
interesting that's an interesting one or
think about it i mean it's just like i
didn't know what a loofah was until i
got to college and i started seeing
other people with them yeah
my wife is definitely a well she used to
be now we got you know we just got
soaps that just do it for you so you
explode you put the soap in the
washcloth and you get it nice and hot oh
if you want to get silly i
you know i so i wet the washcloth yeah i
put all the soap on one side
yeah then i take the soap i put on the
other side and i
squeeze it tight so that way the soap is
inside the water oh i see
and then i scrub that's oh that keeps
the bubbles coming oh yeah yeah exactly
i love it i love it i love it okay so
you got the washcloth method that's
great that's the washcloth
that's great um and then are you like a
five minute
shower guy 10 minute 20 minute 30 minute
how long
um i would say 30 minutes on average
okay you like
really long showers that's cool yeah i'm
just chilling you're just chilling yeah
for sure as long as i can um yeah you
know i i guess
i don't have a routine about when i take
a shower but when i'm in there
i want to do the shampoo i want to do
the soap then i do the conditioner
then i do like uh some sort of like body
scrub that
is supposed to have more benefits than
the irish spring that i grew up on that
i still use
sure for sure so in any case yeah
there's um
cleanliness is is a priority yeah and
but i'm not like
i haven't gotten to the point where i
need to dictate like what i use
yeah yeah i mean i'm waiting for the
entrepreneurs out there to tell me like
this will grow your hair back
this will prevent ingrown hairs oh yeah
because these are annoying sure
what am i supposed to use for my face
like how can i like make scars go away
stuff like this yeah but what about
do you do any shower thoughts and do you
write them down
do you have a journal or like do you do
any of that i don't
write my i do have journals
my i tend to take thinking in the shower
and then i will apply it to like a
business concept yeah it's another
family
so it might i might be thinking through
a business plan or or a pitch deck
or or consciousness or or a better way
to explain euphoria
or a different application of our
algorithms those are the things i think
about um
you know sometimes i'll listen to like
guided messages uh you know
i'm a big fan of like people who you
know share the information that they
that they get through channeling um and
so i'm just a magnet for
you know deeper thoughts like i want i'm
curious about other people's deep
thoughts
um i have my own i love these
conversations because
you know this is the stuff that i feel
is truly important the stuff that i want
to
understand um you know even
reincarnation it's like
it's not supposed to be a thing in one
culture it's super crucial in another
and and when you look at all the
historical stories and
who's moving what needles like
it's it's something that requires us to
pay attention to and
and see what we can do from it i mean
the dalai lama said he was reincarnated
like why is this not a thing
yeah the tibetan book of the dead is
super interesting and they're actually
trying to scientifically
validate rebirth and uh science needs to
become more serious about
and we need to put the right incentives
for science to be able to properly
investigate that so we can understand it
because
that will lead us to a more cyclic idea
of life rather than a um a linear finite
one yeah yolo is fun to say but i don't
know if i believe it
[Laughter]
how about okay so
now let's go let's do so you're on your
way to bed
now you have to take your socks off how
do you take your socks off
one at a time what's your procedure do
you go right to left left to right
i think i go right hand left foot right
hand left foot and then do you fold how
do you fold
do you take it off do you fold do you
just throw it do you go yeah yeah yeah
yeah you get it reverse you
yank it off yeah so you rev you reverse
the sock as you take it i reverse the
socks okay
and then you do a left to right and take
it off and when you when you sleep do
you sleep
do you sleep naked do you sleep in
boxers briefs t-shirt
how do you sleep depends on the season
okay typically shirtless
typically shirtless um yeah
normally wearing like i don't know i got
into pajama pants
oh pajamas yeah yeah
yeah that's right yeah i'm a pj guy um
i think you know in my college days i
just slept in boxers but i didn't have
pjs
so that's where i got it now you got
pj's yeah now we get my wife gets us the
christmas pj's so we match
your match yeah the whole family it's
awesome the whole fam matches at night
we have that we have them matching pj
like movie nights you might do that
tonight
oh that's interesting depends on how
long this has gone and if i'm in trouble
when i get home yeah
that's i i i that's a that's a quite an
interesting that's a good way for fam to
bond matching pj is a movie night yeah
that's what's up
yeah that's what's up that's what you do
with the white that's what you do with
the wife that's what that's what that's
right
you have fun we have fun i love it um
and that's what matters
yes other other thoughts are uh are you
getting like six seven
eight nine hours how many hours of sleep
are you getting less than six
oh you're getting less six per night
yeah i am yeah i
enjoy staying up um i i use my kids as
an excuse
my my my son accident he's like daddy
you need to go to bed so you're not
cranky in the morning and like i stay up
late so i can enjoy
some portion of my day yeah yeah yeah um
i i do like my me time i i crave it and
it's
it's i've found that if i don't relax i
get more stressed like i could sleep for
eight hours but if i don't chill if i
don't relax
i'm cranky the next day yeah and i've
had back pain so eight hours of sleep
like the longer i slept in the bed the
more my back would hurt
so yeah yeah there's that too so i got
in the habit of sleeping less to to
dodge the pain
and just enjoying the evening so um yeah
i go to bed around
one on average and i wake up when the
kids come in so
six 6 30 sometimes seven jeez
okay and then the last question is what
is your favorite food
man so many words just came to my mind
um
lobster lobster is my favorite
i went to i went to brown university
shout out to brown um providence rhode
island and hemingway's
so there's this one seafood restaurant
it's like i saved up all my money of
four years of college to go to this one
place for dinner
like one time and now it's like no
it's i just crave lobster but i'm on the
west coast
so my friend shout out to scott um and
kristen and the nethercuts
we would uh we order we'll fly it in
um from so legal seafoods is you can
order live lobsters from maine
and they're the yummiest officers i've
had so the lobster for me
what's up yeah so ship it in live and
and um and find a friend from
massachusetts that knows how to cook
exactly um oh wow so you guys are
getting lobster yeah so my mom and
sister have gone
vegan for thanksgiving so this will be
unique and then
on the saturday saturday or sunday after
we're doing the lobster
well after okay i see it so yeah i'll be
happy by the end of the week
that's a novel answer love it so far
yeah we have we haven't
we've only been asking the silly ones in
in la for
a couple episodes now but it's a lot of
fun it kind of like loosens up
like then sure tries to humanize some
things we'll keep thinking of silly
things at
the end to ask sure fun stuff
yeah good i'm glad you had i'm glad you
like those and i'm
wow euphoria psychology of sound
excellent work round two glad we got to
unpack thanks man i'm glad you're doing
this so we can have
these rounds in these conversations and
they're important
they're important i think if we can have
them other people can have them
i think as each person
you know makes more mindful
conversations and uses mindful words
that's how we create a better world you
know just one
at a time yes yeah one more step
towards a more evolved and enlightened
state of consciousness and butterfly
affecting from that place
over and over again i completely agree
in building the
the technologies and products that do
that that help us assist in that process
are people like brandon so do support
him guys
the links are in the bio below
check out those links go and download
the euphoria app the ios download link
is in the bio below go download that
you can also check out the white paper
the euphoria app.com website also
brandon's linkedin profile connect with
him there
his email is also in the bio so reach
out to him if you have any collaboration
investor interest or um other interest
for
your uh questions or
other collab stuff reach out let us know
your thoughts in the comments below on
the episode what you guys think
about the psychology of sound we'd love
to hear from you about the things that
brandon was teaching us about
also do support the artists the
entrepreneurs the spiritual leaders the
scientists in your communities and
around the world you can support
simulation all of our links are below
support
us and go and build the future
manifest your dreams into the world we
love you very much thank you for tuning
in
enjoy life i think that's yeah that's it
enjoy
them and enjoy exactly enjoy life
manifest your dreams into the world
that's it
good job brother thanks man that was on
fire i love it awesome thanks everyone
peace